hey guys it's gary vaynerchuk and uh
thanks for watching another gary
vaynerchuk com video I appreciate it I
get a little bit emotional today I was
in a meeting a little bit of a branding
marketing meeting uh me with more and
more brands doing a lot more consulting
doing a lot of that stuff become part of
a little bit part of my world and you
know I'm a little frustrated so I
figured you know what let me make this
video so i can send it to the people i
meet with before so i have to repeat the
same old bull crap over and over it's
this get a little bit business e so you
know if you're in if you're a media
buyer or yeah you're a media buyer for
brands this one's really for you but for
anybody that's curious or maybe you can
use it your pitches or if you're trying
to tell people what's going on it again
just my opinion and who knows what the
heck that means but I love sharing and I
love interacting and I appreciate you
guys watching value of customers I here
so listen I know TV is growing you know
I keep talking about Oh television
newspaper radio it's all dead and you
know long-term yep but like listen radio
newspaper magazine are like me blipping
I mean like what is up yeah was that
getting married I was trying to do like
the funeral song but there are clearly
in all sorts of trouble and even
television at some level I mean with
things like boxy and Hulu and Apple TV
and whatever is the one that figures it
all out of anybody thinks that walking
into their home in 36 months and are not
controlling their television with some
sort of device whether they're watching
content from the web or from a mobile
play or from television or from
something recorded or for paying
something is completely out of their
mind completely so anyway that being
said brands that are living in 2009 with
this tough economy that have to spend
money if you're not reallocating your
money towards social me you're making a
mistake and here's why I think and
whatever that social media means the
value of the customer I hope people
understand it's actually you know what I
know you don't so I'm gonna explain it
I've realized a lot of people don't the
value of a customer is imperative I mean
you look at brains like coca-cola you
know coca-cola is like top three purse I
don't know what the numbers are so I
don't want to spew it but I know that
cokes top users a small percentage it's
called 5% represented like twenty
percent of their business I know at Wine
Library is a retailer our top six
percent of our customers represent
eighteen percent of our biz
this users are not all the same so when
you say oh well television has all you
know I get a Gary you know but you know
the internet or Facebook or Twitter or
whatever these platforms sorry they
don't have as many users television we
can get a million viewers you know and
that's why we pay so much blah blah blah
you're an idiot guys every viewer that
watches television it has no no value in
comparison to somebody that leverages
social media or uses it heavily or works
on the web let's call the internet Jesus
um you know Sally Arkansas that's eating
Doritos and watching a commercial sees
your commercial likes it and may want to
buy your product may get into it Sally
Arkansas who sees your brand on a
website can hit facebook share can copy
the URL can stumble it can dig it can
bit ly short URL it can pass it on the
word of mouth factor of somebody that is
a user in the social media sphere is
4060 a hundred times more valuable
because that is not a viewer a user a
consumer that is a crusader a word of
mouth sprayer get it or you're going to
be gone